All right, Mr. Ken Lane, whenever you're ready, we're going to sing a few of these songs. We hope you enjoy them.
好的，肯·莱恩先生，准备好了我们就开始唱这几首歌，希望你们喜欢。
Yeah, we hope you enjoy them. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass.
是啊，希望你们喜欢。这里是芝加哥 WBEZ 电台的《美国生活》节目。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
What are you staring at?
你盯着看什么呢？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Brassieres. I dig a broad with no brassieres.
胸罩。我喜欢不穿胸罩的女人。
This is a recording from 1962 of Frank Sinatra, Dean Martin, and Sammy Davis Jr. performing in a club outside Chicago. And like everything else about Frank Sinatra, what's fascinating about this recording is how many different people he's able to be all at once-- cutting up on the one hand and then turning around and singing the most vulnerable possible love songs on the other.
这是一段1962年的录音，是弗兰克·辛纳屈、迪恩·马丁和小萨米·戴维斯在芝加哥郊外一家俱乐部表演的片段。和弗兰克·辛纳屈的其他一切一样，这段录音最迷人的地方在于他能同时成为多少个不同的人——一方面表现得玩世不恭，转眼间又能唱出最脆弱动人的情歌。
[SINGING] When you're alone, who cares for starlit skies? Where does it hurt baby? When you're alone.
[歌唱] 当你孤单时，谁会在意星光灿烂的夜空？哪里会痛，宝贝？当你孤单时。
Not three minutes later, he's lashing into a gossip columnist he hates, Dorothy Kilgallen.
不到三分钟后，他又开始猛烈抨击他讨厌的八卦专栏作家多萝西·基尔加伦。
I never met a-- I mean, I've met many, many male finks, but I never met a female fink until I met Dorothy Kilgallen. How's that for an opener?
我从没见过——我是说，我见过很多很多男性卑鄙小人，但我直到遇到多萝西·基尔加伦才见过女性卑鄙小人。这个开场白怎么样？
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
I wouldn't mind if she was a good looking fink.
如果她是个漂亮点的卑鄙小人，我倒也不会介意。
"That such beautiful music should emerge from such vulgarity is one of life's great mysteries," The Washington Star once wrote.
《华盛顿星报》曾写道：“如此美妙的音乐竟出自如此粗俗之人，真是人生的一大谜团。”
The town where she came from, they had a beauty contest when she was 17 years old and nobody won.
她家乡那个小镇，在她17岁那年举办过一场选美比赛，结果没人得奖。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
There was poor little Chinese kid. The boy was standing there. There was nobody else. They gave him the cup because he was better looking than the broads in the line.
有个可怜的中国小孩在那儿站着。当时没别人了。他们就把奖杯给了他，因为他长得比排队的那群女人还要好看。
And this is the way he is on stage with Sammy Davis Jr. In 1962, it was still groundbreaking for a mainstream white performer to be integrating his nightclub act at all. But a good portion of the act is just Sinatra and Martin telling Davis to get off the stage and Davis pleading with them to stay.
这就是他在舞台上对待小萨米·戴维斯的态度。在1962年，主流白人表演者在夜总会演出中接纳黑人参与本身就是开创性的。但表演中有很大一部分只是辛纳屈和马丁叫戴维斯滚下台，而戴维斯恳求他们留下。
Did he ask me out here-- can I sing with you guys? A couple of--
他叫我出来的——我能和你们一起唱吗？几首……
Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey-- I'll dance with you. I'll sing with you. I'll swim with you. I'll cut the lawn with you. I'll go to Bar Mitzvahs with you. But don't touch me.
嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿，嘿——我可以和你跳舞，和你唱歌，和你游泳，和你割草，和你一起参加成人礼。但别碰我。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
A half century after this was recorded, I think what's most striking about it is how many of the jokes are simply about the fact that a black man is on stage with these white guys. I'm going to play you a big chunk of this because it's amazing-- the jokes they make, what the jokes are about, how bare the whole thing is.
在录音过去半个世纪后，我认为最令人震惊的是，许多笑话仅仅是关于一个黑人和这些白人站在同一个舞台上的事实。我要给你们播放很大一部分，因为这太不可思议了——他们讲的笑话，笑话的内容，以及整件事赤裸裸的样子。
Well, now that you're out here, you might as well do something.
好吧，既然你都出来了，那你最好做点什么。
You might as well leave.
你最好还是离开吧。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Hey, how come he got a white stool?
嘿，他怎么有张白色的凳子？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I tell you what-- ladies and gentlemen, may I offer some impersonations for you nice folks?
我告诉你们——女士们先生们，我可以为各位好朋友模仿几个人吗？
Sam, that's a good idea. Why don't you do Paul Revere, get on your horse, and get the hell out of here?
萨姆，这是个好主意。你为什么不去模仿保罗·里维尔，骑上你的马，然后滚出这里？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I tell you what-- do James Meredith of Mississippi.
我告诉你——模仿一下密西西比州的詹姆斯·梅雷迪思。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Help!
救命！
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Ladies and gentlemen, my first impression is that of Mr. Frank Sinatra.
女士们先生们，我的第一个模仿对象是弗兰克·辛纳屈先生。
[SINGING]
[歌唱]
When somebody loves you, it's no good unless she loves you all the way.
当一个人爱你时，除非她全心全意地爱你，否则这毫无意义。
Man, if you like him, you're going to be cuckoo about me.
伙计，如果你喜欢他，那你一定会为我疯狂。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
He's just, if you'll excuse the expression, a carbon copy.
他简直就是，请原谅我的用词，一个翻版。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Sammy Davis Jr. takes a breath and launches into his next impression.
小萨米·戴维斯喘了口气，开始了他的下一个模仿。
Mr. Nat King Cole.
纳特·金·科尔先生。
[SINGING]
[歌唱]
Through the good lean years, yes, and all those in between years.
度过艰难的岁月，是的，还有其间的所有岁月。
You notice he does his people better than he does ours?
你注意到他模仿他自己人比模仿我们更好吗？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Because we're born with a natural sense of rhythm, you nitwit.
因为我们天生有节奏感，你个笨蛋。
That's Sammy Davis Jr. saying that.
那是小萨米·戴维斯在说话。
Hope I'm not out of line, Frank.
希望我没越界，弗兰克。
Hope I'm not out of line, Frank. Then he says--
希望我没越界，弗兰克。然后他说——
We just sit around all day eating chicken and watermelon. Gak, yuck gak.
我们整天坐着吃炸鸡和西瓜。嘎，呀，嘎。
I hope it's clear, this is Sammy Davis Jr. pushing back at Frank, calling out what's happening with his friend. When Sammy Davis Jr. finally sings a duet with Sinatra, it's a duet between a black man and a white man that is imaginable to hear. You cannot imagine this being performed today by a black man and a white man together except in some deeply ironic context. This is a duet that they performed for years together, "Me and My Shadow."
希望大家清楚，这是小萨米·戴维斯在反击弗兰克，揭露他朋友身上的问题。当小萨米·戴维斯最终与辛纳屈合唱时，那是你能想象到的黑人与白人之间的二重唱。你无法想象今天的黑人和白人会一起表演这个，除非是在某种极具讽刺意味的语境下。这是他们一起表演多年的二重唱《我和我的影子》。
[SINGING TOGETHER, OVERLAPPING] Me and my shadow. Closer than pages that stick in a book. We're closer than ripples that play in a brook. Strolling down the avenue. Whereever you'll find him, you'll find me, just look. Closer than a miser or the bloodhounds to Liza, me. Closer than smog is through all of LA. Me and my shadow. Closer than Bobby is to JFK.
[合唱，重叠] 我和我的影子。比粘在书页里的书签还亲密。我们比小溪里嬉戏的涟漪更亲近。漫步在林荫大道。无论你在哪找到他，你都会找到我，看一眼就好。比守财奴或追踪莉莎的猎犬更亲密。比洛杉矶的雾霾更亲密。我和我的影子。比博比和肯尼迪更亲密。
In Frank Sinatra, we see the history of the 20th century. "In Frank Sinatra," the Chicago writer Rennie Sparks put it, "we don't just see a man, we see every man." Here's Rennie.
在弗兰克·辛纳屈身上，我们看到了20世纪的历史。正如芝加哥作家雷尼·斯帕克斯所说：“在弗兰克·辛纳屈身上，我们看到的不仅仅是一个人，我们看到的是每个人。”下面是雷尼。
He's a frail boy crooner in a floppy bow tie. He's an thug smashing his fist through a wall when his shirts come back with too much starch. And he's a bewildered old man falling off a stool during "My Way." Shirley MacLaine says he let her stick her gum behind his ear during takes Some Came Running. But he also liked to grab an ice cube from his drink, thrusting it in the palm of a gaga fan, snarling, "Here, go skate around on it."
他是一个穿着松垮领结、嗓音娇柔的男孩。当他的衬衫上浆太多时，他是一个挥拳砸穿墙壁的暴徒。他是《我的路》唱到一半从凳子上跌落的困惑老人。雪莉·麦克雷恩说，在拍摄《一个跑来的男人》时，他让她把口香糖粘在他的耳后。但他有时也喜欢从酒杯里抓一块冰块，塞进一个疯狂粉丝的掌心里，嘟囔着：“拿着，去上面滑冰吧。”
"I wish someone would hurt you," he told Shirley, "so I could kill them for you."
“我希望有人伤害你，”他对雪莉说，“这样我就可以为你杀了他们。”
[SINGING] She gets far too hungry, babe. Wait there for dinner at eight. She adores the theater, however, doesn't get there late. She'd never bother with someone she'd hate. That is why the lady is a tramp.
[歌唱] 她太饿了，宝贝。等着八点吃晚饭。她崇拜剧院，从不迟到。她绝不会搭理她讨厌的人。这就是为什么这位女士是个流浪汉。
Well, today on our program, of course, the chairman of the board, Frank Sinatra. This weekend marks his 100th birthday. He was born December 12, 1915. And today's program is one that we first broadcast a year before Sinatra died. He died back in 1998. As you'll hear, this show sounds different in certain ways from the shows we do today, but in lots of ways, not so different. The show is an appreciation of Frank Sinatra. But it is also, even more than that, I think, a bunch of people trying to make sense of Sinatra. We have Gay Talese, Michael Ventura. We have Sarah Vowell making a plea to television executives everywhere. We have a quick history lesson for all of you who right now are saying, really, Sinatra? That's what we're doing? Really? Stay with us, pally.
好了，今天节目当然要谈谈董事会主席弗兰克·辛纳屈。这个周末是他100岁生日。他出生于1915年12月12日。今天的节目是我们最初在辛纳屈去世前一年播出的。他于1998年去世。正如你们所听到的，这档节目听起来与我们今天做的节目在某些方面有所不同，但在很多方面又没那么不同。这档节目是对弗兰克·辛纳屈的致敬。但我认为，这更是一群人试图解读辛纳屈的过程。我们有盖伊·塔利斯、迈克尔·文图拉。我们有萨拉·沃威尔向各地的电视主管发出呼吁。对于你们中现在说“真的吗？辛纳屈？我们要谈这个？”的人，我们有快速的历史课。是真的吗？跟着我们，伙计。
[SINGING] That is why the lady, that's why the lady is a tramp.
[歌唱] 这就是为什么这位女士，这就是为什么这位女士是个流浪汉。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Act one, Frank Sinatra has a Cold. So Frank Sinatra's at his peak in the 1950s up through the middle of the 1960s. Those are the years of his greatest recordings. Those are the years of the Rat Pack, the iconic defining years for him. And to see inside the life that he led during those years, during his heyday, one of the best accounts is by journalist Gay Talese. It was first published in Esquire magazine in 1966. It's called "Frank Sinatra Has a Cold."
第一幕，弗兰克·辛纳屈感冒了。弗兰克·辛纳屈在20世纪50年代到60年代中期处于巅峰期。那些年是他录音作品最出色的时期。那是“鼠党”的年代，对他来说是标志性的决定性岁月。要窥探他巅峰时期的生活，最好的记录之一来自记者盖伊·塔利斯。该文最初于1966年发表在《绅士》杂志上，题为《弗兰克·辛纳屈感冒了》。
It is also one of the most famous magazine stories ever written-- or anyway, famous among journalists-- because Talese managed to do this complicated portrait of Sinatra without ever interviewing Sinatra. Sinatra refused to talk to him. So Talese talked to all the people around Sinatra and watched Sinatra. So this is this long, great story with many, many scenes. We only have time for an excerpt here, which Gay Talese agreed to read for us.
这也是有史以来最著名的杂志文章之一——或者至少在记者圈很出名——因为塔利斯在从未采访过辛纳屈的情况下，完成了这幅复杂的辛纳屈画像。辛纳屈拒绝与他交谈。所以塔利斯采访了辛纳屈身边的所有人，并观察辛纳屈。这是一个很长、很棒的故事，有很多很多场景。我们在这里只有时间播放节选，盖伊·塔利斯同意为我们朗读。
Frank Sinatra, holding a glass of bourbon in one hand and a cigarette in the other, stood in a dark corner of a bar between two attractive but fading blondes who sat waiting for him to say something. But he said nothing. He had been silent during much of the evening, except now in this private club in Beverly Hills, he seemed even more distant, staring out through the smoke and the semi-darkness into a large room beyond the bar where dozens of young couples sat huddled around small tables or twisted in the center of the floor to the clamorous clang of folk rock music blaring from the stereo.
弗兰克·辛纳屈一只手拿着一杯波旁威士忌，另一只手拿着一支烟，站在酒吧阴暗的角落里，站在两个迷人但正在老去的金发女郎之间，她们等着他说点什么。但他什么也没说。整个晚上他大部分时间都很沉默，除了现在在这个比佛利山庄的私人俱乐部里，他显得更加遥远，透过烟雾和半昏暗的光线，盯着吧台后面那个大房间，那里有几十对年轻情侣挤在小桌子周围，或者随着立体声喇叭里传出的嘈杂的民谣摇滚音乐在舞池中央扭动。
The two blondes knew, as did Sinatra's four male friends who stood nearby, that it was a bad idea to force conversation upon him when he was in this mood of sullen silence, a mood that had hardly been uncommon during this first week of November, a month before his 50th birthday. Sinatra had been working in a film that he now disliked and could not wait to finish. He was tired of all the publicity attached to his dating the 20-year-old Mia Farrow, who was not in sight tonight.
那两个金发女郎和站在附近的辛纳屈的四个男性朋友都知道，在他这种阴郁沉默的情绪下强迫他交谈是个坏主意，这种情绪在他50岁生日前一个月，即11月的第一周并不罕见。辛纳屈一直在拍一部他现在很讨厌、迫不及待想拍完的电影。他厌倦了所有关于他和20岁的米娅·法罗约会的报道，而她今晚不在场。
He was angry that a CBS television documentary of his life, to be shown in two weeks, was reportedly prying into his privacy, even speculating on his possible friendships with mafia leaders. He was worried about his starring role in an hour long NBC show entitled, Sinatra, A Man and His Music, which would require that he sing 18 songs with a voice that, at this particular moment, just a few nights before the taping was to begin, was weak and sore and uncertain.
他很生气，两周后要播出的关于他生平的哥伦比亚广播公司电视纪录片据报道正在窥探他的隐私，甚至推测他可能与黑手党领袖有交情。他担心自己在NBC一小时节目《辛纳屈，一个人和他的音乐》中的主演角色，该节目要求他用一个在录制开始前几晚听起来脆弱、酸痛且不确定的嗓子唱18首歌。
Sinatra was ill. He was a victim of an ailment so common that most people would consider it trivial. But when it gets to Sinatra, it can plunge him into a state of anguish and deep depression, panic, even rage. Frank Sinatra had a cold. Sinatra with a cold is Picasso without paint, Ferrari without fuel, only worse. For the common cold robbed Sinatra of that uninsurable jewel, his voice, cutting into the core of his confidence.
辛纳屈病了。他患的是一种大多数人会认为微不足道的常见病。但当它降临到辛纳屈身上时，会让他陷入痛苦、抑郁、恐慌甚至愤怒的状态。弗兰克·辛纳屈感冒了。感冒的辛纳屈就像没有颜料的毕加索，没有燃料的法拉利，甚至更糟。因为普通感冒夺走了辛纳屈那颗无法保险的宝石——他的嗓音，切入了他自信的核心。
And it affects not only his own psyche, but also seems to cause a kind of psychosomatic nasal drip within dozens of people who work for him, drink with him, depend on him for their own welfare and stability. A Sinatra with a cold can, in a small way, send vibrations through the entertainment industry and beyond as surely as a president of the United States suddenly sick can shake the national economy. For Frank Sinatra was now involved with many things involving many people-- his own film company, his record company, his private airline, his missile parts firm, his real estate holdings across the nation, his personal staff of 75, which are only a portion of the power he is and has come to represent.
这不仅影响了他自己的心理，似乎还引起了为他工作、与他共饮、依赖他来维持自身福祉和稳定的几十个人的身心性鼻塞。感冒的辛纳屈在某种程度上，能像美国总统突然患病动摇国民经济一样，给娱乐业内外带来震动。因为弗兰克·辛纳屈现在涉及许多与许多人有关的事情——他自己的电影公司、唱片公司、私人航空公司、导弹零件公司、全国的房地产、75人的私人员工，这些只是他所代表的力量的一部分。
He now seemed to be also the embodiment of the fully emancipated male, perhaps the only one in America-- the man who can do anything he wants, anything-- can do it because he has the money, the energy, and no apparent guilt. All the way. All or nothing at all. This is Sicilian in Sinatra. He permits his friends, if they wish to remain that, none of the easy Anglo-Saxon outs. But if they remain loyal, then there is nothing Sinatra will not do for them-- fabulous gifts, personal kindnesses, encouragement when they're down, adulation when they're up.
他现在似乎也是完全解放了的男性的化身，也许是美国唯一的一个——这个男人可以做他想做的任何事，任何事——可以做到，因为他有钱、有精力，而且没有明显的负罪感。全力以赴。要么全有，要么全无。这就是辛纳屈身上西西里的一面。他绝不允许他的朋友（如果他们还想做朋友的话）有任何盎格鲁-撒克逊式的轻易脱身的借口。但如果他们保持忠诚，辛纳屈就会为他们做任何事——奢华的礼物、个人的善举、失意时的鼓励、得意时的奉承。
They are wise to remember, however, one thing-- he is Sinatra, the boss, Il Padrone. Or better still, he is what in traditional Sicily have long been called oumini rispetatti-- men of respect. Men who are both majestic and humble. Men who are loved by all in are very generous by nature. Men whose hands are kissed as they walk from village to village. Men who would personally go out of their way to address a wrong. Frank Sinatra does things personally.
然而，他们最好记住一件事——他是辛纳屈，老板，教父。或者更好的是，他就是传统西西里岛长期以来所说的“受尊重的人”——受人尊敬的男人。既威严又谦逊的男人。被所有人爱戴且天生慷慨的男人。在村庄间行走时会被亲吻双手的男人。会亲自为纠正错误而走访他人的男人。弗兰克·辛纳屈做事亲力亲为。
At Christmas time, he will personally pick dozens of presents for his close friends and family, remembering the type of jewelry they like, their favorite colors, the size of their shirts and dresses. This same Sinatra can, within the same hour, explode in a towering rage of intolerance to a small thing being incorrectly done for him by one of his paisanos. For example, when one of his men brought him a frankfurter with ketchup on it, which Sinatra apparently abhors, he angrily threw the bottle at the man, splattering ketchup all over him.
圣诞节时，他会亲自为亲密的朋友和家人挑选几十份礼物，记住他们喜欢的珠宝款式、颜色、衬衫和裙子的尺码。而同一个辛纳屈，在同一小时内，可能会因为他的一个同乡做错了一件小事而大发雷霆。例如，当他的人给他带来一个抹了番茄酱的法兰克福香肠，而辛纳屈显然讨厌番茄酱时，他愤怒地把瓶子扔向那个人，溅了他一身番茄酱。
In Las Vegas after the last show at The Sands, the Sinatra crowd, which numbered about 20, all got into a line of cars and headed for another club. It was 3 o'clock. The night was young. They stopped at The Sahara, taking a long table near the back, and listened to a bald headed little comedian named Don Rickles, who is probably more caustic than any other comic in the country. His humor is so rude, in such bad taste, that it offends no one because it's too offensive to be offensive.
在拉斯维加斯，最后一场演出结束后，辛纳屈那群人（大约20个）坐成一排车前往另一个俱乐部。当时是凌晨3点。夜生活还很早。他们在撒哈拉酒店停下，在后面找了一张长桌，听一个名叫唐·里克斯的秃头小个子喜剧演员表演，他可能是全国最尖刻的喜剧演员。他的幽默如此粗鲁，品味如此糟糕，以至于不会冒犯任何人，因为它太冒犯了，反而显得不具冒犯性。
Spotting Eddie Fisher among the audience, Rickles proceeded to ridicule him as a lover, saying it was no wonder that he could not handle Elizabeth Taylor. And when two business men in the audience acknowledged that they were Egyptians, Rickles cut into them and their country's policy toward Israel. And he strongly suggested that the woman seated at one table with her husband was actually a hooker. When the Sinatra crowd walked in, Don Rickles could not be more delighted.
里克斯在观众中发现了埃迪·费舍尔，便开始嘲笑他作为情人的无能，说难怪他搞不定伊丽莎白·泰勒。当观众中两个商人承认他们是埃及人时，里克斯抨击了他们及其国家对以色列的政策。他强烈暗示坐在某张桌子上的一位已婚女士其实是个妓女。当辛纳屈那群人走进来时，唐·里克斯别提有多高兴了。
Pointing to Sinatra's pal Jilly Rizzo, Rickles yelled, "How's it feel to be Frank's tractor? Yeah, yeah. Jilly keeps walking in front of Frank, clearing the way." Then nodding to Leo Durocher, a former baseball player, Rickles said, "Stand up, Leo. Show Frank how you slide." Then he focused on Sinatra, not failing to mention Mia Farrow, nor that he was wearing a toupee, nor to say that Sinatra was washed up as a singer. And when Sinatra laughed, everybody laughed.
里克斯指着辛纳屈的死党吉利·里佐喊道：“当弗兰克的拖拉机感觉如何？耶，耶。吉利总是走在弗兰克前面，清路。”然后向曾经的棒球运动员里奥·杜罗彻点头，里克斯说：“站起来，里奥。给弗兰克表演一下你怎么滑垒。”然后他把焦点对准辛纳屈，没忘了提米娅·法罗，也没忘了提他戴着假发，也没忘了说辛纳屈歌手生涯已完蛋。当辛纳屈笑了，大家都笑了。
And Rickles pointed towards Joey Bishop and said, "Bishop keeps checking with Frank to see what's funny."
里克斯指向乔伊·毕晓普说：“毕晓普一直在看弗兰克，想看什么好笑的。”
Then after Rickles told some Jewish jokes, Dean Martin stood up and yelled, "Hey, you're always talking about the Jews, never about the Italians." And Rickles cut him off, "What do we need the Italians for? All they do is keep the flies off our fish." Sinatra laughed. They all laughed. And Rickles went on this way for nearly an hour until Sinatra, standing up, said, "All right, all right. Come on, get this thing over with. I got to go. "Shut up and sit down," Rickles yelled. "I had to listen to you sing."
然后，里克斯讲了几个关于犹太人的笑话后，迪恩·马丁站起来大喊：“嘿，你总是在谈论犹太人，从来不谈意大利人。”里克斯打断他：“我们需要意大利人干什么？他们唯一的作用就是把苍蝇赶走，别让它们落在我们的鱼上。”辛纳屈笑了。他们都笑了。里克斯就这样说了一个多小时，直到辛纳屈站起来说：“好了，好了。快点，把这事儿了结了吧。我得走了。”“闭嘴坐下，”里克斯大喊。“我不得不听你唱歌。”
"Who do you think you're talking to?" Sinatra yelled. "Dick Haymes," Rickles replied, and Sinatra laughed again. And then Dean Martin, pouring a bottle of whiskey over his head, entirely drenching his tuxedo, pounded the table.
“你以为你在跟谁说话？”辛纳屈喊道。“迪克·海姆斯，”里克斯回答，辛纳屈又笑了。然后迪恩·马丁把一瓶威士忌倒在自己头上，浑身湿透了他的燕尾服，猛地拍桌子。
By 4:00 AM, Frank Sinatra led the group out of The Sahara, some of them carrying their glasses of whiskey with them, sipping it along the sidewalk and into the cars. And then returning to The Sands, they walked into the gaming casino. It was still packed with people. The roulette wheels were spinning. The crap shooters were screaming in the far corner. Frank Sinatra, holding a shot glass of bourbon in his left hand, walked through the crowd.
凌晨4点，弗兰克·辛纳屈领着大家离开撒哈拉酒店，有些人手里拿着酒杯，沿着人行道抿着酒上车。然后回到金沙酒店，他们走进赌博大厅。那里依然挤满了人。轮盘转动着。掷骰子的人在远处的角落里尖叫。弗兰克·辛纳屈左手拿着一杯波旁威士忌，走过人群。
He, unlike some of his friends, was perfectly pressed-- his tuxedo tie precisely pointed, his shoes unsmudged. He never seems to lose his dignity, never lets his guard completely down, no matter how much he has drunk nor how long he's been up. He never sways when he walks like Dean Martin, nor does he dance in the aisles or jump up on the tables like Sammy Davis. A part of Sinatra, no matter where he is, is never there. There's always a part of him, though sometimes a small part, that remains Il Padrone.
他与朋友不同，着装完美——燕尾服领带系得恰到好处，皮鞋一尘不染。他似乎从不失态，无论喝了多少酒，或是熬了多久，他的防备从未彻底放下。他不像迪恩·马丁那样走路摇晃，也不像萨米·戴维斯那样在过道里跳舞或跳上桌子。辛纳屈无论身在何处，总有一部分是不在现场的。他总有一部分，尽管有时很小，依然保持着“教父”的威严。
The crowd that had gathered around him now opened to let him through. But a woman stopped in front of him, handing him a piece of paper. He signed it and then he said thank you. In the rear of The Sands large dining room was a long table reserved for Sinatra. The dining room was fairly empty at this hour with perhaps two dozen other people in the room, including a table of four unescorted young ladies sitting near Sinatra. On the other side of the room at a long table sat seven men shoulder to shoulder against the wall, two of them wearing dark glasses, all of them eating quietly, speaking hardly a word. Just sitting and eating and missing nothing.
围在他身边的人群现在散开让他通过。但一个女人停在他面前，递给他一张纸。他签了字，然后说了声谢谢。金沙酒店大餐厅的后面有一张为辛纳屈预留的长桌。此时餐厅相当空，大约有二十多个人，包括坐在辛纳屈附近的一张坐着四个无人陪伴的年轻女士的桌子。房间另一侧的一张长桌旁坐着七个男人，背靠墙肩并肩坐着，其中两人戴着墨镜，他们都静静地吃着，几乎不说一句话。只是坐着、吃着，不错过任何细节。
The Sinatra party, after getting settled and having a few more drinks, ordered something to eat. The table was about the same size as the one reserved for Sinatra whenever he's at Jilly's in New York. And the people seated around this table in Las Vegas were mainly the same people who are often seen with Sinatra at Jilly's restaurant in New York, or at a restaurant in California, or in Italy, or New Jersey. Wherever Sinatra happens to be.
辛纳屈一行人安顿下来又喝了几杯后，点了些东西吃。桌子的大小和辛纳屈在纽约吉利餐厅用餐时预留的桌子差不多。坐在拉斯维加斯这张桌子周围的人，主要也是那些经常与辛纳屈在纽约吉利餐厅，或在加州、意大利、新泽西餐厅里出现的人。无论辛纳屈在哪里，他们就在哪里。
When Sinatra sits to dine, his trusted friends are close. And no matter where he is, no matter how elegant the place may be, there's something of the neighborhood showing because Sinatra, no matter how far he has come, is still something of the boy from the neighborhood. Only now, he can take his neighborhood with him. In some ways the quasi-family affair at the reserved table in a public place is the closest thing Sinatra now has to home life.
当辛纳屈坐下用餐时，他信任的朋友们就在身边。无论他在哪里，无论那个地方多么优雅，总会流露出一些街坊邻里的味道，因为辛纳屈无论走了多远，骨子里还是那个邻里间的男孩。只是现在，他可以把他的邻居带在身边。在某种程度上，公共场所预留桌旁的准家庭聚会，是辛纳屈现在最接近家庭生活的方式。
Gay Talese, reading an excerpt from "Frank Sinatra has a Cold." A quick Google search and you can read the full thing online.
盖伊·塔利斯朗读了《弗兰克·辛纳屈感冒了》的节选。只需在谷歌上搜索一下，你就可以在线阅读全文。
Act two, One Sinatra Fan Versus All of Network Television. So as I said earlier, for Frank Sinatra's hundredth birthday, we're bringing you an old show that we made back when Sinatra was still alive, first broadcast a year before his death. He died in 1998. And in our original broadcast, one of our contributors, Sarah Vowell, made a plea to television newscasters. Her plea was simple. She said when Frank Sinatra dies, please, please do not use the song "My Way" to commemorate his death.
第二幕，一个辛纳屈粉丝对阵全网电视。正如我之前所说，为了弗兰克·辛纳屈的百岁诞辰，我们带来了一期老节目，那是他在世时制作的，首播于他去世前一年。他于1998年去世。在我们最初的广播中，我们的撰稿人之一萨拉·沃威尔向电视新闻主播发出了呼吁。她的请求很简单。她说，当弗兰克·辛纳屈去世时，请千万不要用《我的路》这首歌来纪念他。
Don't let that be the soundtrack to the video montage you broadcast in tribute. She was sure that's what they were going to do.
不要让这成为你们广播悼念视频的配乐。她肯定他们会这么做。
When the guy, who generously gave us greats like "I Get a Kick Out of You" kicks it, we won't put on our Basie Boots or get a load of those cuckoo things he's been saying. We'll be bored terrifically, screaming at the TV set every time he and that sappy string section face the final curtain.
当这个慷慨给了我们像《我为你疯狂》这样伟大的经典人物去世时，我们不会穿上我们的贝西靴，也不会去听那些他唱过的疯狂曲目。我们会被无聊透顶，每次他和那忧伤的弦乐伴奏面对“最后的帷幕”时，我们都会对着电视机尖叫。
[SINGING] And now--
[歌唱] 现在——
A few weeks ago, here on the radio program, I went on a little rant about one of the lyrics to the song "My Way." But Sarah's problem with "My Way" was much more fundamental than mine. Basically she said, it doesn't have any of the qualities of the great Sinatra songs. It doesn't swing. It doesn't break your heart. It's sappy. It's boring. It's even a little whiny. Anyway, here's more of Sarah.
几周前，就在这档广播节目中，我就《我的路》的歌词发了一通牢骚。但萨拉对《我的路》的问题比我的更根本。基本上她说，它没有任何伟大的辛纳屈歌曲的品质。它不摇摆，不感人。它很做作。它很无聊。甚至有点爱抱怨。总之，这是更多关于萨拉的内容。
The only way "My Way" has ever worked is if the person singing it is dumber than the song, which is why the only successful rendition of it was perpetrated by Sid Vicious. Frank, and Elvis for that matter, was always too complicated, too full of rhythmic freedom, to settle into the song's simplistic selfishness. "My Way" pretends to speak up for self-possession and personal vision when really it only calls forth the temper tantrums of two-year-olds, or perhaps the last word spoken to Eva Braun.
《我的路》唯一行得通的方法是演唱者比这首歌更蠢，这就是为什么唯一成功的翻唱是由席德·维瑟斯完成的。弗兰克，还有猫王，总是太复杂，太充满节奏自由，无法沉溺于这首歌简单的自私之中。《我的路》假装在为个人意志和愿景代言，而实际上它只唤起了两岁孩子的脾气，或者说是对伊娃·布劳恩说的最后一句话。
[SINGING] The record shows I took the blows and did it my way.
[歌唱] 唱片显示我承受了打击，并且用我自己的方式做到了。
Remember the stories from Belgrade? How each night, when the government-controlled evening news aired, the townspeople blew whistles or banged on pots and pans so they wouldn't hear the state's lies? Keep that beautiful action in mind when Sinatra is dead and all the TVs in your more boring democratic world are playing "My Way." Drown it out. Play something else to the montage in your own heart. Or just turn off the TV sound. Have your stereo cued up and ready to go.
还记得贝尔格莱德的故事吗？每晚当政府控制的晚间新闻播出时，镇民们就吹口哨或敲打锅碗瓢盆，这样他们就不会听到国家的谎言。当辛纳屈去世，而你们在更无聊的民主世界里的所有电视都在播放《我的路》时，请记住这个美丽的行动。掩盖住它。在你们心中为蒙太奇播放点别的。或者干脆关掉电视声音。准备好你们的音响。
He could keel over any second. I mean, he might not even make it through this hour long radio show. Be prepared. Why not play "Angel Eyes" for its subtle reference to the singer's Mediterranean windows to the soul, for its knowing, jaunty adieu?
他随时可能倒下。我的意思是，他甚至可能撑不过这一个小时的广播节目。做好准备。为什么不播放《天使之眼》，因为它微妙地提到了这位歌手通往灵魂的窗户，因为它那充满知情、轻快的告别？
[SINGING] Excuse me while I disappear.
[歌唱] 原谅我先消失了。
Hear how great that would work under all those post-war black and white snapshots, how that nice Christian harp outro hints at Frank's unlikely salvation. Let's all listen again.
听听这首歌在那些战后黑白照片下会有多棒，那可爱的基督教竖琴结尾暗示了弗兰克那不可能的救赎。让我们再听一遍。
Excuse me while I disappear.
原谅我先消失了。
I admit, this may not be quite stupid and obvious enough for network television. So if the staff of the Today Show is hearing my voice right now, here's another suggestion.
我承认，这对于电视网来说可能不够愚蠢和明显。所以如果今天节目的工作人员现在正在听我的声音，这里有另一个建议。
[SINGING] That's life. That's what all the people say. You're riding high in April, shot down in May.
[歌唱] 这就是生活。这就是人们所说的。你在四月如日中天，在五月被击落。
If "Angel Eyes" is all periods and pauses, this song is all exclamation points. Picture please, Good Morning America staffers, quick cut shots of Sinatra with Ava Gardner, Sinatra with daughter Nancy at age five, Sinatra with Kennedy, Sinatra with some mob boss no one will recognize anyway, over these lyrics--
如果说《天使之眼》全是句号和停顿，这首歌就全是感叹号。照片请准备好，早安美国的工作人员们，快速剪辑辛纳屈与艾娃·加德纳的照片，五岁的辛纳屈与女儿南希，辛纳屈与肯尼迪，辛纳屈与没人认得出来的黑帮老大的照片，配上这歌词——
[SINGING] I've been a puppet, a pauper, a pirate, a poet, a pawn and king. I've been up and down and over and out, and I know one thing. Each time I find myself flat on my face, I pick myself up and get back in the race. That life. I tell you--
[歌唱] 我曾是个傀儡、乞丐、海盗、诗人、棋子和国王。我经历过起起落落，也走到了尽头，我只知道一件事。每次发现自己跌倒时，我都会爬起来继续参加比赛。这就是生活。我告诉你——
It's really a terrible choice-- just as corny as "My Way", but at least it's got a little bit of the old ring-a-ding-ding. It swings. This is my ABMY vote-- Anything But "My Way." As for me, when I hear the big news, I'm tempted to think I'll be cranking up my favorite Sinatra side, "Come Dance With Me", but it's too disrespectfully cheerful to work as a dirge and kind of creepy if taken literally. Who, except Tom Petty, wants to fox trot with a corpse?
这真是一个糟糕的选择——就像《我的路》一样老套，但至少它有一点旧时的摇滚味。它摇摆。这就是我的投票——除了《我的路》，选什么都行。至于我，当我听到那个重大消息时，我很想播放我最喜欢的辛纳屈曲目《来和我跳舞》，但它太不敬地欢快了，不适合做挽歌，而且如果从字面上理解，有点令人毛骨悚然。除了汤姆·佩蒂，谁想和尸体跳狐步舞？
I've decided instead to blare the Capitol recording of Cole Porter's "What is This Thing Called Love?" It's the driving question behind the entire Sinatra research project and it's a lovely pop song, suitably melancholy for mourning, reflective, and wise. The orchestra starts off low. Enter a clarinet that's somehow lewd and ponderous at the same time. Frank scrawls the topic sentence, then repeats it, adding one word-- this funny thing called love.
我决定播放科尔·波特的《这叫爱情的东西》的国会唱片版本。这是整个辛纳屈研究课题背后的驱动问题，它是一首可爱的流行歌曲，足以表达忧伤，反思且睿智。管弦乐队从低处开始。进入一支单簧管，它既淫荡又沉重。弗兰克写下了主题句，然后重复它，加了一个词——这叫爱情的有趣东西。
It begins as a rhetorical question and by the end turns into a cosmic inquiry of God.
它始于一个修辞性问题，到最后变成了对上帝的宇宙探询。
[SINGING] What is this thing called love? This funny thing called love. Just who can solve its mystery? And why should it make a fool of me?
[歌唱] 到底什么是这叫爱情的东西？这有趣的叫爱情的东西。到底谁能解开它的谜团？为什么它会让我像个傻瓜？
Now ET producers, are you paying attention? At the end of the song, Frank asks one more time to the Lord in heaven above, just what is this thing called love? And then he cuts out, as if he's off to face the creator in person.
现在ET的制作人，你们在听吗？在歌的结尾，弗兰克最后一次向上帝询问，到底什么是这叫爱情的东西？然后他退场了，仿佛他要去亲自面对造物主。
[SINGING] That's why I ask the Lord up in heaven above just what is this thing called love?
[歌唱] 这就是为什么我向上帝询问，到底什么是这叫爱情的东西？
And then, once he's gone, the orchestra resolves to a sweet, final chord, as if they have the answer, but Frank Sinatra is no longer around to hear it. Can't you just see the freeze frame? Frank, in the recording studio, the Capitol years, the hat askew, the tie loosened. TV producers of America, I beg you for all of us, for Frank, ixnay on the "My Way." Excuse me now while I disappear.
然后，当他走后，管弦乐队以一个甜蜜的最终和弦结束，仿佛他们有了答案，但弗兰克·辛纳屈已不在身边去听它了。你能看到定格画面吗？弗兰克在录音室里，国会岁月，帽子歪着，领带松开了。美国的电视制作人，我代表我们所有人请求你们，为了弗兰克，别再播《我的路》了。原谅我现在先消失了。
[MUSIC - "MY WAY" BY SID VICIOUS]
[音乐 - 席德·维瑟斯的《我的路》]
While Sarah Vowell's plea to network television was broadcast twice, twice on our program before Sinatra's death, his death on May 14, 1998, it had no effect whatsoever on television newscasters. Every network newscast used the song "My Way" in its network obituary. So much for the power of public radio to shape our nation's destiny. The one exception was ABC's Nightline . The night that Sinatra died, Nightline ended a special hour long tribute they'd created to Sinatra by playing Sarah's radio story.
虽然萨拉·沃威尔向电视网的呼吁在我们节目中播出过两次，但在辛纳屈1998年5月14日去世后，它对电视新闻主播没有产生任何影响。每个电视网的新闻节目在其讣告中都使用了《我的路》这首歌。公共广播塑造国家命运的能力也就这样了。唯一的例外是美国广播公司的《夜线》。在辛纳屈去世的那晚，《夜线》以播放萨拉的广播故事，结束了他们为辛纳屈制作的一个小时特别专题报道。
In other words, the person who got the last word in American network news that day, the day of Sinatra's passing, was Sarah. Her essay has been collected in one of her many fine books, Take the Cannoli .
换句话说，那天在辛纳屈去世的消息中，美国电视网新闻里拥有最后发言权的人，是萨拉。她的文章被收录在她许多优秀的书籍之一《带上坎诺利》中。
Coming up, Frank Sinatra shifts through all of his different ages in one concert. That's in a minute on Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，弗兰克·辛纳屈在一场演唱会中穿越了他所有的不同年龄。稍后继续，请关注芝加哥公共广播电台的节目。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week, of course, we choose a theme, invite a variety of writers and performers to take a whack at that theme with fiction, nonfiction, radio monologues, whatever we can think of. And the subject of today's show-- what, what was his name again?
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周，我们当然会选定一个主题，邀请各种作家和表演者通过小说、非小说、电台独白等我们能想到的任何形式来探讨这个主题。而今天节目的主题是——他叫什么名字来着？
[SINGING] My name is Frances Albert.
[歌唱] 我的名字是弗朗西斯·艾伯特。
[SINGING] Francis Albert Sinatra.
[歌唱] 弗朗西斯·艾伯特·辛纳屈。
[SINGING] And I sing love songs mostly after dark, mostly in saloons.
[歌唱] 我唱情歌，大多在天黑之后，大多在酒馆里。
Yes, you cannot have a career as long and distinguished as Frank Sinatra's without some experiments that fail. Witness Frank Sinatra's cover of "Bad, Bad Leroy Brown" or the Rod McKuen poetry he recorded.
是的，没有一些失败的实验，你就不可能拥有像弗兰克·辛纳屈那样漫长而杰出的职业生涯。看看弗兰克·辛纳屈翻唱的《坏坏的勒罗伊·布朗》或他录制的罗德·麦奎恩的诗歌。
I can just about get through the day, but the night makes me nervous. Not for any reason, except maybe that it catches you unaware and follows you the way a woman follows when she wants something.
我勉强能熬过白天，但夜晚让我紧张。没什么特别原因，除了也许它会让你措手不及，就像女人想要什么东西时跟在你身后一样。
What-- what is that? The night makes Frank Sinatra nervous? Frank Sinatra? But that is not what I'm really here to talk about here in Act Three. What I'm really here to talk about is not the failures of Frank Sinatra, but what makes Sinatra so special in the first place. And the answer is, from the time of his first big breakthrough as a solo singer in 1942, Frank Sinatra was more emotionally expressive, more vulnerable, more openly sensual, than other male pop stars back then.
什么——那是什么？夜晚让弗兰克·辛纳屈紧张？弗兰克·辛纳屈？但这并不是我第三幕真正想谈的。我真正想谈的不是弗兰克·辛纳屈的失败，而是到底是什么让辛纳屈如此特别。答案是，从1942年他作为独唱歌手首次突破以来，弗兰克·辛纳屈比当时的其他男性流行歌星更具情感表现力、更脆弱、更公开地展现性感。
He was a torch singer, a guy torch singer, who picked up moves from Billie Holiday. Sinatra said Holiday influences singing more than anybody. And then in the 1950s, he didn't let go of all that, but he reinvented himself. After a career slump, after his second marriage with Ava Gardner broke up, he went into the studio to create records with a much tougher, more swinging sound than he'd done before. His public image became the character Frank Sinatra, who we know now-- half tough guy, half sentimental saloon singer.
他是一个火炬歌手，一个男火炬歌手，他从比莉·荷莉黛那里学到了技巧。辛纳屈说荷莉黛对歌唱的影响超过任何人。然后在50年代，他没有放弃这一切，而是重塑了自己。在职业低谷后，在他与艾娃·加德纳的第二次婚姻破裂后，他进入录音室创作了一些比他以前更强硬、更摇摆的音乐。他的公众形象变成了我们现在认识的弗兰克·辛纳屈这个角色——一半是硬汉，一半是感伤的酒馆歌手。
And Nelson Riddle invented this sound for those albums with apparently heavy input from Sinatra. It's the sound of most of the songs that we think of today as Sinatra standards.
尼尔森·里德尔为这些专辑发明了这种声音，显然辛纳屈投入了大量意见。这就是我们今天认为的辛纳屈标准曲的大部分声音。
[SINGING] Those fingers in my hair, that sly come-hither stare that strips my conscience bare, it's witchcraft.
[歌唱] 手指掠过我的秀发，那狡黠的招魂凝视，赤裸了我的良知，这就是巫术。
Music writer Will Friedwald says that the sound that Riddle invented for Sinatra is built around bass trombone, flute, muted trumpet, and strings. And there's this lightness to the orchestration, with a much more complicated mix of melodies and counter-melodies on different instruments than other composers were using then on pop records. Witness, for example, how Riddle used trumpeter Harry "Sweets" Edison.
音乐作家威尔·弗里德瓦尔德说，里德尔为辛纳屈发明的这种声音是围绕低音长号、长笛、弱音小号和弦乐构建的。编曲有一种轻盈感，与当时其他作曲家在流行唱片中使用的旋律和对位旋律的混合相比，要复杂得多。例如，看看里德尔如何使用小号手哈里·“甜点”·爱迪生。
Essentially he was not hired as a trumpeter to sit in the section, but he was hired strictly as a soloist or and obligatist. And he would not sit in the section. But he had his own-- he would sit to the side and had his own special microphone. And so Sweets would just improvise these little trumpet fills here and there on the muted trumpet.
从本质上讲，他不是被雇来坐在声部里的小号手，而是被严格雇佣为独奏者或助奏者。他不会坐在声部里。但他有自己的——他会坐在旁边，有自己专门的麦克风。所以“甜点”会在弱音小号上即兴演奏这些小填补。
And when he plays, he's only playing almost in between the breaths.
当他演奏时，他几乎只在呼吸之间演奏。
Well, as Gary Giddins points out, Sweets essentially plays three kinds of solos-- beep, beep beep, and beep beep beep.
正如加里·吉金斯指出的那样，“甜点”本质上演奏三种独奏——哔、哔哔、哔哔哔。
Let me play a little bit of this. He comes in here, if I understand right, right after Sinatra sings "with people she'd hate."
让我播放一点这个。如果我理解得没错，他是在辛纳屈唱完“与她讨厌的人”之后进来的。
[SINGING] She loves the theater, but never comes late. She'd never bother with people she'd hate. That's why the lady is a tramp.
[歌唱] 她喜欢剧院，但从不迟到。她绝不搭理她讨厌的人。这就是为什么这位女士是个流浪汉。
He's going to come back again in a couple seconds.
几秒钟后他会再次出现。
[SINGING] She'll have no crap games with sharpies and frauds. And she won't go to Harlem in Lincolns or Fords. And she won't dish the dirt.
[歌唱] 她不会和骗子、骗徒玩双陆棋。她不会坐着林肯或福特去哈莱姆。她不会搬弄是非。
Which brings  us to Act Four, the Death of Frank Sinatra. Michael Ventura grew up in the 1950s in New York.
这就带我们进入第四幕，弗兰克·辛纳屈之死。迈克尔·文图拉在50年代的纽约长大。
I'm Sicilian on both sides of my family. And if you grew up as a Sicilian kid in the '50s in New York, it was like Sinatra was part of your family. He was the most famous Italian except for some baseball stars. Literally, just a figure people gossiped about and they listened to his songs and he was held up to me by my father as an example. You see him? He can spit in anybody's and get away with it.
我家两边都是西西里人。如果你在50年代作为西西里小孩在纽约长大，辛纳屈就像是你家庭的一部分。他是除了几个棒球明星之外最著名的意大利人。字面上讲，他只是人们谈论八卦、聆听歌曲的人物，他被我父亲树立为榜样。你看他吗？他可以冲任何人吐口水，还能全身而退。
When Michael Ventura published a novel in 1996 called The Death of Frank Sinatra , Sinatra's people were not pleased. The book, however, is not literally about Frank Sinatra. It's about men like Michael Ventura, whose sense of style and sense of self came in part from Frank's style. What's it mean to you, the death of Frank Sinatra?
当迈克尔·文图拉在1996年出版了一部名为《弗兰克·辛纳屈之死》的小说时，辛纳屈的随从们并不高兴。然而，这本书并不是真的关于弗兰克·辛纳屈。它是关于像迈克尔·文图拉这样的人，他们的风格感和自我感部分来自于弗兰克的风格。弗兰克·辛纳屈的死对你意味着什么？
The death of a style. The death of the last and greatest embodiment of a kind of street elegance, a style that is particularly and indelibly 20th century and that we will not see again.
一种风格的消逝。最后也是最伟大的某种街头优雅的化身，一种特别且难以磨灭的20世纪风格，我们将不会再见到它了。
Of course, he wrote his book long before hip hop artists like Jay Z adopted Sinatra as their own. Frank Sinatra himself only appears in this book once. In the scene that he's in, he's doing a concert. And one of the things that's interesting is that in a work of fiction, Michael Ventura could choose to write about a Sinatra concert from any era Sinatra was alive. And Ventura decided on the mid-1990s, the last years of Sinatra's life.
当然，他在Jay Z等嘻哈艺术家接纳辛纳屈为他们自己之前很久就写了这本书。弗兰克·辛纳屈本人在这本书中只出现过一次。在他出现的场景中，他正在进行演唱会。有趣的一点是，在虚构作品中，迈克尔·文图拉可以选择描写辛纳屈生前任何时期的演唱会。文图拉决定选择90年代中期，也就是辛纳屈生命的最后几年。
The reason why, he says, is because in the old man, you get Sinatra at all of his ages. You can still hear the young man and the middle aged man and the old man, all of them, when he sang. Here's Ventura reading from that part of his book.
他说理由是，因为在老人身上，你可以看到各个年龄段的辛纳屈。当你唱歌时，你仍然可以听到年轻人、中年人和老年人，所有他们。下面是文图拉朗读他书中的那部分。
As the old man walked out onto the stage, a curtain came up behind him to reveal a large orchestra. Every musician wore a tuxedo. The conductor was a small, round man sitting at a grand piano and wearing earphones. With a slash of the conductor's hand, the rhythm and brass burst into a loud uptempo number and Sinatra flashed a smile that made him look uncannily young. A young smile, on the old pasty face. And his eyes were the same as they had always been-- brighter in person than they ever registered on screen.
当老人走上舞台时，身后的幕布拉开，露出了一个大型管弦乐队。每个音乐家都穿着燕尾服。指挥是一个身材圆润的小个子男人，戴着耳机坐在大钢琴前。随着指挥的一挥手，节奏和铜管乐爆发出一首响亮的快节奏乐曲，辛纳屈露出的笑容使他看起来年轻得不可思议。年轻的微笑，在苍老蜡黄的脸上。他的眼睛还是和以前一样——比在屏幕上看起来更明亮。
And like the smile, the eyes were young to the point of seeming unnatural. For though no makeup could conceal the sad ravages of the face, the eyes and the smile seemed untouched. As though to put his listeners at ease with these contradictions, Sinatra grabbed the microphone from the top of the black grand piano and sang about how they made him feel so young. These strangers in this room had that power. They made him feel so young and he would feel that way even when he was old and gray. The song itself was keeping him alive.
就像笑容一样，眼睛年轻到看起来很不自然。因为虽然没有任何妆容能掩盖脸上悲伤的岁月痕迹，但眼睛和笑容似乎未受影响。仿佛为了让他听众适应这些矛盾，辛纳屈从黑色大钢琴顶上抓住麦克风，唱起他们如何让他感觉如此年轻。房间里的陌生人拥有那种力量。他们让他感觉如此年轻，即使他老态龙钟，也会有这种感觉。歌曲本身在让他活着。
The first bars were the voice of the old man-- raspy, worn, unable to hold notes for longer than a beat. And only his mastery of rhythm kept the song alive and made each word surprising. Surprising, though everyone in the room knew the lyrics by heart. Then on a high note, the voice cracked. And for an instant, the music soured and the audience flinched as one person. But instead of retreating from that bad sound, Sinatra leaned into it. Sinatra bent the note further into a jazz-like harmony.
前几小节是老人的声音——沙哑、疲惫，无法保持音高超过一拍。只有他对节奏的掌握让歌曲存活下来，并使每个字都令人惊讶。令人惊讶，尽管房间里的每个人都倒背如流这首歌词。然后在一个高音上，声音破了。一瞬间，音乐变味了，观众齐刷刷地畏缩了一下。但辛纳屈没有退缩，反而加大了音量。辛纳屈把音符弯曲成更像爵士乐的和声。
And then instead of softening after the mistake, Sinatra held the new note longer and louder, as though diving into it, then took a quick breath and sang the next note, louder still, and fuller, until seamlessly for several bars, it was the voice of 30 or 40 years ago-- full and unfettered, resonant and suggestive. Until, again, it began to crack. And again, he used the cracking to modulate back into the voice and style of the old man-- on pitch, but raw, one note per beat, sometimes right on the beat, sometimes just off it-- keeping the performance tense until, on the last note, the young man's voice returned, as though saluting the old man who sang it.
然后，在错误之后，辛纳屈没有软化，反而将新音符保持得更长、更大声，仿佛潜入其中，然后快速喘了口气，唱出下一个音符，声音更大、更饱满，直到连续几小节无缝连接，那是30或40年前的声音——饱满而奔放，共鸣且富有感染力。直到再次开始破裂。而他再次利用破裂音调制回老人的声音和风格——音高准，但生涩，一拍一个音，有时准点，有时偏离——使表演保持紧张，直到最后一个音符，年轻人的声音回归，仿佛向唱出这一声的老人致敬。
And Sinatra let that note ride and the audience cheered. It was a breathless performance, like watching a trapeze artist work without a net. I lit my cigarettes like he did. I wore the kind of clothes he wore. I still do. I tried to stand as he stood. I tried to walk as he walked. I still do. Not because I was imitating him, but because I was imitating all the people who gave and taught me life and they took so many of their cues from him.
辛纳屈让那个音符漂浮，观众欢呼。这是一场令人窒息的表演，就像看着空中飞人在没有安全网的情况下工作。我像他一样点烟。我穿着他那样的衣服。我至今仍这样做。我试着像他那样站立。我试着像他那样走路。我至今仍这样做。不是因为我在模仿他，而是因为我在模仿所有给予我生命、教导我生命的人，他们从他身上学到了很多暗示。
And where had he taken his cues from? From peasants who came to America from an older, less sentimental world. Peasants, who came with the intention of becoming aristocrats and who, almost as soon as they arrived, began to stand and walk like those aristocrats they had watched so closely, yet from afar, for generations. European princes had taught them grace. American streets taught them flare. They didn't need to learn violence from anyone. That they were born with.
那么他又从哪里学来的呢？从那些来自更古老、不那么感伤世界的农民那里。那些怀着成为贵族意图来到美国的农民，他们几乎一抵达就开始模仿那些他们世代在远处密切观察过的贵族。欧洲王子教给他们风度。美国街道教给他们闪光。他们不需要向任何人学习暴力。那是他们与生俱来的。
And Sinatra blended all this better than any and sang as he did so. Sang of love and of pride, despairing of one and revelling in the other. And this is why Sicilians especially gave him respect in the peculiar way Sicilians use that word, meaning homage, deference, consideration, and that invitation to betrayal, loyalty. Now Sinatra sang about how they, whoever they were, couldn't take that, whatever that was, away from him. That somehow in the way she held her hat and the way she sipped her tea was beyond the world's possibility to destroy or erode.
辛纳屈把这一切融合得比任何人都好，并在这样做的时候歌唱。歌唱爱情和自豪，对前者感到绝望，对后者感到陶醉。这就是为什么西西里人对他特别尊重，以西西里人使用那个词的奇特方式，意味着敬意、服从、考虑，以及那种通往背叛的邀请——忠诚。现在辛纳屈唱着他们（无论他们是谁）如何夺不走那东西（无论那东西是什么）。不知何故，她拿帽子的方式和她啜茶的方式，是世界无法摧毁或侵蚀的。
There was a scrapbook of Sinatra's pictures. The pictures were all of Sinatra, but he was never alone. Sinatra with Lyndon Johnson, with Adlai Stevenson, with Eleanor Roosevelt. He was holding her hand and looking into her eyes. With Jack Kennedy, Bobby, Jackie, Nixon, Reagan, Nancy. And Sinatra with very different people. Sinatra with Johnny Roselli, Paul Castellano, Carlo Gambino, Carlo's son Joey, Jimmy Fratianno, Sally Spatola.
有一本辛纳屈照片的剪贴簿。照片里全都是辛纳屈，但他从不孤单。辛纳屈与林登·约翰逊、阿德莱·史蒂文森、埃莉诺·罗斯福。他握着她的手，看着她的眼睛。与杰克·肯尼迪、博比、杰基、尼克松、里根、南希。还有辛纳屈与非常不同的人。辛纳屈与约翰尼·罗塞利、保罗·卡斯特拉诺、卡洛·甘比诺、卡洛的儿子乔伊、吉米·弗拉蒂亚诺、萨利·斯帕托拉。
And still another kind. Sinatra with Marilyn Monroe, Lauren Bacall, Humphrey Bogart, Marlon Brando, Louis Armstrong, Elvis Presley, Duke Ellington. That man on the stage, that old man, was where it all connected. Who else had held the hand of Eleanor Roosevelt and shaken the hand of Carlo Gambino both and on equal terms? That man on the stage, that old man. And why? Because he could sing love songs like no one else-- history, of a kind.
还有另一种类型。辛纳屈与玛丽莲·梦露、劳伦·白考尔、亨弗莱·鲍嘉、马龙·白兰度、路易斯·阿姆斯特朗、猫王、艾灵顿公爵。舞台上的那个男人，那个老人，是这一切连接的地方。还有谁握过埃莉诺·罗斯福的手，又平等地握过卡洛·甘比诺的手？舞台上的那个男人，那个老人。为什么？因为他能唱出与众不同的情歌——一种历史。
History transfixed by love songs. That's life. That's what all the people say the man is singing now. Some people get their kicks from stomping on a dream, but he don't let that get him down. And now he's singing that we're much too marvelous for words. The man was speaking now. I'm just waiting for a downbeat, not a bus. Where you working tomorrow? The musicians laughed. The conductor, that little round man, laughed. That's my son, the guy with the earphones. I had to promise his mother I'd give the bum a job.
被情歌震撼的历史。这就是生活。那个人现在唱着这就是人们所说的一切。有些人从践踏梦想中获得快感，但他没有让那让他沮丧。现在他在唱我们美妙得无法言喻。那个人现在在说话。我只是在等强拍，不是公车。你明天在哪里工作？音乐家们笑了。那个小圆胖指挥笑了。那是我儿子，戴耳机的那个家伙。我得答应他妈给这混蛋一份工作。
More laughter. But something was wrong on the stage. The music was playing, but Sinatra wasn't singing. He was looking around as though he's forgotten where he was. He started a lyric, then stopped. It didn't fit the music. He looked frightened, a scared boy in the body of an old man. He turned toward his son, whose presence seemed to remind him of who he was. He was Frank Sinatra. He was there to sing love songs to history. And he wheeled around and began to beg, but in the proudest terms, that luck be a lady tonight and that she keep the party polite.
笑声更多了。但舞台上出了点问题。音乐在响，但辛纳屈没唱。他环顾四周，好像忘记了自己在哪。他开始唱一句词，然后停下了。那不合音乐节奏。他看起来很害怕，一个被困在老人体内的受惊小男孩。他转向他的儿子，儿子的存在似乎提醒了他他是谁。他是弗兰克·辛纳屈。他来这里是为了向历史唱情歌。他转身开始恳求，但用最自豪的措辞，请求今晚好运成为一位女士，请求她保持聚会的礼貌。
But it had been an awful moment. He took a few steps, tried to recover. Slowly, he started to speak. I'm what they call a saloon singer. The song began. He's telling us to drink up, all we happy people. Nobody here looks very happy, but he's admitting that we're happier than him. He says he's paying for the drinks and the laughs. He's paying for everything because a woman with angel eyes is gone. And she's really gone. He's not bitter. He's not angry at her.
但这太糟糕了。他走了几步，试着恢复。慢慢地，他开始说话。我是所谓的酒馆歌手。歌曲开始了。他告诉我们喝下去，所有快乐的人们。这里没人看起来很快乐，但他承认我们比他快乐。他说他在付酒钱和笑声。他在支付一切，因为一个有天使之眼的女人离开了。而且她真的离开了。他不苦涩。他不生她的气。
Those angel eyes had every right to look elsewhere. He asks us to excuse him because he must disappear. And his voice is disappearing with him, a scratchy whisper like an old wax record played on an old machine. With unbearable politeness, with a tenderness close to death, the death of his voice, he is saying excuse me. I must disappear. There are no angel eyes left in the room. No reason to stay.
那些天使之眼完全有权看别处。他请我们原谅他，因为他必须消失。他的声音也正随他消失，像老机器上播放的老蜡质唱片一样的沙哑低语。以无法忍受的礼貌，以接近死亡的温柔，随着他嗓音的死亡，他在说原谅我。我必须消失。房间里再没有天使之眼了。没有留下来的理由。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
We put one in every performance, if you've seen us perform before. And it's called a saloon song. I do one in each performance because somebody, somewhere, sometime dubbed me the saloon singer. So I don't want to disappoint him. And it would happen to have a lot of truth, in fact, to that too. Because when I really young and I started working in joints in New Jersey and bars and grills and all kinds of places. Until one day somebody came in and offered me a better job. Look what happened to me? Nothing.
如果你之前看过我们表演，我们每场表演都有一首这样的歌。它被称为酒馆歌曲。我在每场表演中都唱一首，因为某个地方、某个时间，有人给我冠以“酒馆歌手”的称号。所以我不想让他失望。事实上，这确实包含了很多真相。因为当我真的很年轻的时候，我开始在新泽西的廉价小酒吧、烧烤店和各种地方工作。直到有一天，有人进来给了我一份更好的工作。你看我经历了什么？什么也没有。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
[SINGING] Drink up-- drink up all you people. Order anything that you see. And have fun all you lovely people. The drink and the laughs on me.
[歌唱] 喝下去——喝下去，你们所有的人。点任何你们看到的。祝你们这些可爱的人玩得开心。酒和笑声算我的。
I tried to think that love's not around. Still, it's uncomfortably near. My poor old heart, it's not gaining any ground, because my angel eyes, she ain't near.
我试图认为爱已不在身边。但它仍然离得不舒服地近。我可怜的老心，并没有得到任何安慰，因为我的天使之眼，她不在身边。
Act Five, Chairman of the Block. Now that Sinatra's dead and gone, I think there's a kind of kitsch version of Sinatra that has replaced the real guy in lots of people's minds. The kitsch version is way less complicated, kind of a Vegas cartoon rat pack Sinatra. It leaves out the Billie Holiday side of Sinatra. It leaves out the raw vulnerability of Sinatra. It overlooks the originality of what he invented. So there's that kitsch Sinatra that's out there. And at the same time, there are a lot of people who really love Sinatra and remember Sinatra.
第五幕，街区主席。现在辛纳屈已经去世了，我认为在许多人的心中，辛纳屈已经被一种媚俗的版本所取代。媚俗的版本复杂性少得多，有点像拉斯维加斯卡通鼠党的辛纳屈。它丢掉了辛纳屈比莉·荷莉黛的一面。它丢掉了辛纳屈原始的脆弱感。它忽视了他发明的原创性。所以外面有那个媚俗的辛纳屈。与此同时，也有很多人真正热爱辛纳屈，怀念辛纳屈。
We'll close today's program with another story that we first broadcast years ago. This is about a man who loves Sinatra and how he used that love, for a while, to do something for his entire neighborhood. To spread the joy. One of his neighbors, Blake Eskin, tells the story.
我们今天节目的结尾将播放另一个我们几年前首次播出的故事。这是关于一个热爱辛纳屈的男人，以及他如何利用这份爱，在一段时间里为他整个邻里做了一些事情。为了传播快乐。他的邻居之一，布雷克·埃斯金，讲述了这个故事。
I went out one Friday evening with a friend in the East Village where we both live. On the street, we heard Frank Sinatra music blasting loud enough to wake the neighbors.
周五晚上，我和一个朋友去了我们居住的东村。在街上，我们听到弗兰克·辛纳屈的音乐声音大得足以惊醒邻居。
[SINGING] Fairy tales can come true. It can happen to you.
[歌唱] 童话可能会成真。它可能会发生在你身上。
As we reached Fourth Street, I saw a hundred people huddled around the stoop of a six floor tenement. Most of them were post-college, pre-child bearing types. Plus there were some older people who probably lived on the block. Everyone seemed to have forgotten where they were headed, whether to a party or to another bar or back to bed.
当我们到达第四街时，我看到一百个人挤在一栋六层公寓的门廊周围。他们大多是大学毕业、未生育的类型。另外还有一些可能住在这条街上的老年人。每个人似乎都忘了他们要去哪儿，无论是去参加派对、去另一家酒吧，还是回床上睡觉。
[SINGING] You will go to extremes with impossible schemes--
[歌唱] 你会走向极致，带着不可能的计划——
A short, dark-haired guy in a suit stood at the top of the stoop holding a microphone. At first, I thought maybe the guy was lip syncing. But after a few seconds, I realized he was doing the crooning himself. The guy looked a little like Sinatra and he moved like him, too. But this was no run of the mill Sinatra impersonator. It was as if he was possessed by the spirit of Sinatra, channeling the Chairman of the Board.
一个穿着西装、深色头发的小个子男人站在门廊顶上拿着麦克风。起初，我以为那个家伙是在对口型。但几秒钟后，我意识到他是自己在哼唱。那个家伙看起来有点像辛纳屈，动作也像他。但这绝不是普通的辛纳屈模仿者。就好像他被辛纳屈的灵魂附身，在传达董事会主席的精神。
[SINGING] She gets too hungry for dinner at eight. She adores this theater but she never arrives late. Come over here, Susan.
[歌唱] 她太饿了，等着八点吃晚饭。她崇拜剧院，但从不迟到。过来这里，苏珊。
At the bottom of the stoop was someone you would not ordinarily see with Frank Sinatra. An older woman with spiky salt and pepper hair and a leopard print vest was doing a spirited, if slightly awkward, tap dance on a piece of wood she had dragged out onto the sidewalk.
门廊底部是一个你通常不会和弗兰克·辛纳屈一起看到的人。一个有着尖尖的椒盐色头发、穿着豹纹马甲的老年妇女，正在拖到人行道上的一块木头上跳着精神抖擞、虽稍显笨拙的踢踏舞。
[SINGING] She doesn't like crap games with barons and earls. Won't go dressed to a party all up in some other girl's pearls. She won't dish the dirt with the rest of those girls. That's why this chick is a champ.
[歌唱] 她不喜欢和男爵、伯爵玩双陆棋。不会盛装打扮去参加别人的派对。她不会和其他女孩一起搬弄是非。这就是为什么这个姑娘是个冠军。
After my initial confusion and my subsequent bliss, my next reaction was to wonder how this was possible. Where were the cops? The 9th precinct is a block away and New Yorkers are quick to complain about noise. But on Fourth Street, everything was copacetic. And it still is. Somehow, by some quirk of fate, the show outside 124 East Fourth Street has happened five Fridays in a row. The singer, Nick Drakides, lives on the first floor of the building and the tap dancer, Laraine Goodman lives on four.
在我最初的困惑和随后的喜悦之后，我的下一个反应是想知道这怎么可能。警察呢？第9分局就在一个街区外，纽约人对噪音投诉很快。但在第四街，一切都井然有序。现在也是。不知何故，出于某种命运的安排，东第四街124号门外的演出已经连续五个周五发生了。歌手尼克·德拉基德斯住在楼房的一楼，踢踏舞者拉莱恩·古德曼住在四楼。
Gary and Wanda, who run the garden level thrift shop, put their merchandise, the chairs, and overstuffed couches on the sidewalk for the audience's comfort.
经营花园层旧货店的加里和旺达，把他们的商品——椅子和塞满东西的沙发——放在人行道上，为了观众的舒适。
[SINGING] She'd never bother with some bum that she'd hate. I said that's why Laraine is a champ. Nick Drakides and Laraine Goodman are neighbors. And like most people who live in the same building, they didn't know much about each other. Laraine did know, however, that Nick had a big jazz record collection. Five weeks ago, Laraine decided she wanted to tap dance in front of the building. As a sort of therapy, she says.
[歌唱] 她绝不会搭理她讨厌的流浪汉。我说这就是为什么拉莱恩是个冠军。尼克·德拉基德斯和拉莱恩·古德曼是邻居。和大多数住同一栋楼的人一样，他们对彼此了解不多。不过拉莱恩确实知道，尼克有很大的爵士唱片收藏。五周前，拉莱恩决定她想在楼前跳踢踏舞。作为一种治疗，她说。
And she reached out to Nick, asking him to play some tunes while she tap danced that weekend.
于是她联系了尼克，请他在那个周末跳踢踏舞时播放一些曲子。
Because what happened was, I was coming home. I'll tell you exactly what happened. When I was coming home that Friday evening around nine o'clock and I forgot her name. And I'm walking down Fourth Street from Second Avenue and I'm like, oh, there she is tapping. And I don't want to do this. I'm tired. I'm like, ugh. And then I had to reach for her name in my little-- in my pocket. What's this thing? Pocket day timer.
事情是这样的，我当时正回家。我告诉你到底发生了什么。那个周五晚上大约九点钟我回家，忘了她的名字。我沿着第四街从第二大道走下来，我想，哦，她在跳舞。我不想做这个。我很累。我想，呃。然后我不得不伸手去口袋里找她的名字。那是什么东西？口袋里的日期记录本。
And I'm like, it's Laraine. Then I walked down the street and I said, hi, Lorraine. How are you? And she goes, oh come on out, Nick, and join me. Blah, blah, blah. And I think she assumed I'd bring out some music. That was it. I don't think she was expecting a suit and microphone stand and the PA, the CDs, the cassettes, the whole number.
然后我想，是拉莱恩。然后我走在街上说，嗨，拉莱恩。你好吗？她说，噢，出来吧，尼克，加入我。巴拉巴拉巴拉。我想她以为我会带点音乐出来。就是这样。我不认为她期待的是一套西装、麦克风架、PA音响、CD、卡带，整套装备。
Thanks to Laraine Goodman. This is the brains behind this wonderful event here. Say good evening, Laraine.
感谢拉莱恩·古德曼。这是这个美妙活动背后的策划人。打个招呼，拉莱恩。
Good evening, Laraine.
晚上好，拉莱恩。
Nick's initial gesture of kindness to Laraine, a near stranger, made her into a local celebrity and made himself into an even bigger one. There were only a handful of people watching Laraine tap dance when Nick went outside with his instant Sinatra kit, which includes a few CDs from a series called "Pocket Songs." The discs have the full Sinatra arrangements without a vocalist. The slogan is "You sing the hits."
尼克最初对几乎是陌生人的拉莱恩的善举，使她成为当地名人，也使他自己成为了更大的名人。当尼克带着他即时的辛纳屈套件（包括一系列名为“袖珍歌曲”的CD）出来时，只有少数人在看拉莱恩跳舞。这些唱片有辛纳屈的全套编曲，没有主唱。口号是“你唱金曲”。
Nick began with "I've Got the World on a String." The crowd built steadily. And right away, Nick had the crowd on a string, standing on the stoop, had the string around his finger. What a world.
尼克以《我把世界系在弦上》开始。人群稳定增加。尼克立刻就把人群系在了弦上，站在门廊上，弦绕在他的手指上。多么好的世界。
[SINGING] What a world, what a life. I'm in love. I've got a song that I sing--
[歌唱] 多么好的世界，多么好的生活。我在恋爱。我有一首我唱的歌——
Nick showed me a picture taken when he was 15. He's wearing a tuxedo, his hair parted to the side, standing at a microphone and pointing back at the camera. It is a picture of a 15-year-old boy from Poughkeepsie, New York in Frank Sinatra drag.
尼克给我看了一张他15岁时拍的照片。他穿着燕尾服，头发分向一侧，站在麦克风前，指着镜头。那是一个15岁来自纽约波基普西男孩扮演弗兰克·辛纳屈的照片。
I'm basically-- what I'm doing right now, I have been into since I was a kid, since I was 10 years old.
我基本上——我现在做的这些，我从孩子起就热衷了，从10岁起。
[SINGING] We've got the world on our string and we're swinging on a rainbow. We've got the string around our finger. What a world, what a life. We all are in love.
[歌唱] 我们把世界系在我们的弦上，我们在彩虹上摇摆。我们把弦绕在手指上。多么好的世界，多么好的生活。我们都恋爱了。
Each of us in the audience had been lured by the improbability of the situation. But Nick's stage presence kept us there. Nick really knows how to work a room, even when it's not a room. He weaves his neighbor's names into the lyrics.
我们观众中的每个人都被这种情况的不可思议所吸引。但尼克的台风让我们留了下来。尼克真的很会活跃气氛，即使那不是个房间。他把邻居的名字编进歌词里。
[SINGING] Any time he moves his-- there's Brendan, our lovely neighbor here. Lucky me. How you doing, Ritchie? Can't you see? I'm in love. Life is a beautiful thing.
[歌唱] 任何时候他移动他的——那是布兰登，我们可爱的邻居。幸运的我。你好吗，里奇？你没看见吗？我在恋爱。生活是件美好的事。
He plugs Gary and Wanda's thrift shop and thanks them for their help. He salutes a couple watching from a nearby fire escape. Now it's a safe bet that if Nick and Laraine had been break-dancing or playing conga drums, the police would have shut them down in 20 minutes tops. But the officers of the 9th precinct fell under the same spell as the rest of us and they couldn't bring themselves to get out of the patrol car to enforce the mayor's quality of life rules.
他宣传了加里和旺达的旧货店，感谢他们的帮助。他向从附近火灾逃生梯上观看的一对情侣致敬。现在可以肯定地说，如果尼克和拉莱恩是在跳霹雳舞或敲康加鼓，警察会在20分钟内把他们轰走。但第9分局的警官们像我们其他人一样中了魔咒，他们无法让自己下警车去执行市长的生活质量规则。
The first week, they would circle around the block, speak through their megaphone. They would say, people please don't block the streets, you know? Please keep the streets clear. And that it. That was the first week. The second week they requested "Summer Wind."
第一周，他们会绕着街区转，通过扩音器说话。他们会说，各位请不要阻碍街道，知道吗？请保持街道畅通。就这样。那是第一周。第二周他们点了《夏日风》。
They requested "Summer Wind?"
他们点了《夏日风》？
Yes.
是的。
Through the megaphone?
通过扩音器？
Through the megaphone as they were passing. The third week, the third week the police came and they stopped their car, held up traffic, and they said, OK, "Summer Wind." They wanted to hear "Summer Wind." So I finished "Night and Day", I put "Summer Wind" on. And I went up on the steps. They manipulated their lights on the top into white spotlight on me and I started singing "Summer Wind."
当他们经过时，通过扩音器。第三周，第三周警察来了，他们停下车，阻挡了交通，他们说，好吧，《夏日风》。他们想听《夏日风》。所以我唱完《昼夜》，放上了《夏日风》。我上了台阶。他们把车顶的灯光调成白色聚光灯照在我身上，我开始唱《夏日风》。
The crowd went crazy. Evidently, it's that whole New York, macho, Italian, police, Irish, street-- and evidently what I'm doing, they connect with that.
人群疯了。显然，那是一种纽约式的、大男子主义的、意大利式的、警察的、爱尔兰式的、街头的——显然我做的事情，他们与此产生了共鸣。
[SINGING] The summer wind, it came blowing in from across the sea.
[歌唱] 夏日风，它从海对面吹来。
Of course they do. So do the black men with dreadlocks, the young white guys in Wu Tang Clan t-shirts, the teenagers immersed in the swing lounge scene, the potbellied Italian men of a certain age, smoking cigars. And, sitting front row center, wearing a party-colored mumu, Nick's next door neighbor, Jean, who has lived at 124 East Fourth Street for the last 48 years. For all of them and for me, there is something about Frank Sinatra and something about how Nick Drakides interprets Frank Sinatra that bewitches us, that touches us.
当然他们会。留脏辫的黑人、穿武当派T恤的年轻白人、沉浸在摇摆乐场景中的青少年、抽着雪茄的中年意大利大肚子男人们也是如此。还有坐在前排中心、穿着彩色长袍的尼克邻居吉恩，她在东第四街124号住了48年了。对他们所有人以及对我来说，弗兰克·辛纳屈身上有一种东西，尼克·德拉基德斯演绎弗兰克·辛纳屈的方式有一种东西，让我们着迷，触动我们。
[SINGING] I sit like painted kites, those days and nights, they went flying by.
[歌唱] 我坐着像彩绘的风筝，那些日子和夜晚，它们飞走了。
There's a guy who's lives next door and he embraced me. He hugged me, this old Chinese guy, man, with a hearing aid. I'm like, I touched this guy. I don't know how I did it, but I did it. You know?
有个住隔壁的家伙，他拥抱了我。他拥抱了我，这个老中国男人，伙计，戴着助听器。我想，我触动了这个家伙。我不知道我是怎么做到的，但我做到了。你知道吗？
[SINGING] Hey now, the autumn wind and the winter winds, they have come and they have gone.
[歌唱] 嘿，现在，秋天的风和冬天的风，它们来了又走了。
For any New Yorker to do something as big as this for his neighbors, again and again, is more than an anomaly. It is as rare and unstable as the elements at the bottom of the periodic table. The key ingredients of this event-- neighborliness, generosity, free time, good weather, cooperative police officers-- are hard to come by in this city. And they are nearly impossible to find together in the same place, week after week.
对于任何纽约人来说，能如此反复地为邻居做这么大的事，不仅仅是一个异常。它像元素周期表底部元素一样稀有且不稳定。活动的这些关键成分——邻里情、慷慨、空闲时间、好天气、配合的警官——在这个城市很难得到。而在同一个地方，周复一周，几乎不可能同时找到。
There's a gossip columnist in the New York Post named Cindy Adams. And it is tempting to resort to her mantra, "only in New York, folks, only in New York" to explain this phenomenon. But in Nick's case, the wisdom of Cindy Adams does not suffice. This is not the stuff of New York, not of the real New York or even of the New York of a bygone era, but of a mythical movie New York, a Lower East Side block built on a studio back lot.
《纽约邮报》有个八卦专栏作家叫辛迪·亚当斯。为了解释这种现象，很容易诉诸她的口头禅，“只有在纽约，伙计们，只有在纽约”。但在尼克的情况里，辛迪·亚当斯的智慧还不够。这根本不是纽约的素材，不是真正的纽约，甚至不是往昔岁月的纽约，而是一个神话般的电影纽约，建立在片场摄影棚里的下东区街道。
It is the first reel of an unknown MGM Musical from just after the war and it stars Nick Drakides. What happens in the rest of the film is anyone's guess.
这是战后米高梅音乐剧的首卷，尼克·德拉基德斯主演。电影剩下的部分会发生什么，谁也不知道。
[SINGING] Strangers in the night, exchanging glances, wondering in the night, what were the chances we'd be sharing love.
[歌唱] 夜晚的陌生人，交换着眼神，思索着在夜晚，我们分享爱情的机会有多少。
Blake Eskin, in New York.
布雷克·埃斯金，在纽约。
[SINGING] It's quarter to three. There's no one in the place except you and me. So set up, Joe. I got a little story you ought to know. We're drinking my friend to the end of a brief episode. Make it one for my baby and one more for the road.
[歌唱] 现在是三点差一刻。除了你和我，这儿没人。所以准备好，乔。我有件小事你该知道。朋友们，我们为了这短暂插曲的终点干杯。给我一杯，再给路上一杯。
Well, the original program we did about Frank Sinatra back in 1997 that most of today's show came from was produced by Peter Clowney and Sarah Vowell, with Alix Spiegel and Nancy Updike. Contributors editors on that show including Paul Tough, Jack Hit, and Margie Rockland. Lily Sullivan and Matt Tierney helped remake it into today's program.
好吧，我们1997年制作的关于弗兰克·辛纳屈的原始节目，今天大部分内容都来自那期节目，由彼得·克劳尼和萨拉·沃威尔制作，艾丽克斯·斯皮格尔和南希·厄普代克参与。该节目的贡献编辑包括保罗·塔夫、杰克·希特和玛吉·洛克兰。莉莉·沙利文和马特·蒂尔尼协助将其重制为今天的节目。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. Thanks as always to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia, who of course we always refer to around here as the Boss, Il Padrone. I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托雷·马拉蒂亚先生，我们在这里总是称他为老板，Il Padrone。我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
[MUSIC - "ONE FOR MY BABY" BY FRANK SINATRA]
[音乐 - 弗兰克·辛纳屈的《给我一杯》]